you've been doing stand-up for 60 years
we were just talking in the break and
you still do it you're still out there
you're still going out well I kind of
kind of semi-retired and my wife and I
and we moved out of a big house into a
not as busy not as big a house yeah
and I was there about a month and then
Jenny said to me yeah you go nuts aren't
you yeah I said yeah I'm going nuts yeah
she said okay go get some dates yeah
yeah yeah so you went back out you went
back out and I think there's nothing
wrong with that you're a fan I mean
people love it they love to see you it's
what you were born to do so why not do
it that's the first thing I did and it's
I mean as long as I have my health
there's no reason not to do it I mean
it's it's somebody you know I'm really
I'm really sick of making people laugh
you know right right right
the why would you say it's upsetting did
you you've performed you from I would
imagine in every single kind of venue
you know small clubs when you were
getting started back in the 60s you know
big showrooms in Vegas
you know massive halls what about
outdoor venues have you ever performed
outdoor venues those can be problematic
yeah because I played a date in um in in
Georgia Atlanta Georgia a place called
Chastain Park and it was like the stage
was covered but the audience wasn't
covered you know and it just it was like
a downpour and and so people they had
they were expecting it to rain so they
had their umbrellas you know and and so
it's all now I don't see anyone all I
see is is is umbrellas you know and so
I'd start start
I do say something in there did this one
umbrella starts do you know yeah and
then then another one and then pretty
soon the whole of the whole Ollie all
the umbrellas and I said to myself oh I
gotta remember that line that got a
great day jiggle Biggles like that oh
yeah no no no you got to keep that one
did did stand up it's so funny because
you had this completely different career
you were an accountant count yeah you're
an accountant and became a stand-up did
it come easy to you right away
did you have success right away stand-up
no no I I played a club I won't mention
where but they did two shows a night so
I went out and two shows a night seven
days a week and I died every single not
one laughs have not a snicker it was a
rough beginning but you know but there
isn't there isn't a stand-up in the
world who hasn't
who hasn't died I mean it's just you
never not to this day I mean 60 years
you never know would you live we'll walk
out there and yeah you can hear the air
conditioning you know I can
[Music]
I do hear it it's so funny you say that
because you know I was just mentioning
before he came out that I've been doing
this for 25 years now thousands and
thousands of hours of standing there
talking to audiences I would say it goes
well more often than it doesn't go well
oh but there it but there are but there
are times where I come out and I tell it
a joke and the first joke goes great and
then I threw the second joke and I hear
I actually hear the air-conditioning
because yeah absolute nothing and I've
actually come to enjoy it almost didn't
matter because if you comment on it and
you say you know I can hear my own heart
beating ladies and gentlemen or I guess
that one we should have left on it there
with you then because they at least know
like alright you know that didn't work
and it's like it's like it's nice to
know you're not gonna get a laugh like
you don't have to worry about is this
gonna work or not gonna work right
because you know you're gonna walk out
and hear the air conditioning yeah yeah
yeah you ain't too far no no it's like
an old friend yeah you know so yeah
so great about more than you know we
obviously Jack Benny I'm a huge fan and
you were a huge fan a massive influence
and he influenced so many people Johnny
Carson yourself just a whole generation
of comedians who then influenced another
generation of comedians but what you
mastered I think better than anybody is
the pause you take these amazing pauses
and that was what's always been so
distinctive about your act is that
you're so you you will take the time and
there'll be a long pause and that was
such a important part of your record
when it first came out and then I know
that you had some problems because one
of the engineers I guess thought that he
could improve the record right yeah I
made that I made the album and then they
figured well oh there's there's some
silence we can we can save some time
there it's a step and it drove me nuts
could I it was it wasn't the way I
wasn't you and it wasn't any distinct
did it yeah yeah okay
in fact I we've been flying on a plane
and that's when they used to have the
comedy stuff in and some people would be
listening to me doing the driving
instructor or whatever and I I would
almost want to get up and say please let
me do it for you
really I want to put the pauses back I
just can't imagine you working up and
down the aisle
okay I'm gonna do this for you it's
gonna be great it is such such an honor
and a treat when you stop by the show I
cannot thank you enough
I love it
you